it's rewind time
and then ricegum
it's rewind time for night
for tonight
welcome everybody happy thanksgiving
it is i and my beautiful wife and
co-host and business partner
and a spouse you're basically everything
to me
and i don't mean that like like i mean
like literally
you're everything no i mean it's not
it's really just a statement
romantic no like like fact yeah yeah
seriously business partner wife
best friend best friend lover i mean
love her just for we have sex
but i'm trying to be romantic like love
her no we have sex so that i count on
you for
we we co-parents co-parent
host co-host co-host i mean it's
ridiculous
yeah what else
did we say business we said we started
with business um
that's it yeah i mean i don't know what
other titles there are but i'm sure
i'm sure it's nice i mean the fact that
we still get along is pretty impressive
yeah i agree i mean you think about it i
agree totally you know
it's pretty incredible that we can share
so much to get there and still
like not hate each other i think no
you don't hate me do you i know i'm not
good i would not be here
thank god and i think and ela hates most
people so
i hate a lot it's pretty great
that's one of my crowning achievements
is life and life is to not be hated by
ela
i don't like it she does like it okay
today's episode is sponsored by harry's
razors and ridge wallet
i hope you guys enjoyed our thanksgiving
special we did if you haven't seen it go
back and watch for pete take but only
after you're done watching this episode
obviously
right right when you're right you're
right this is new teddy fresh by the way
it comes out
on december first elasti
what a big picture but that's the next
level
let me see oh the custom zip we got
custom zips
guys how was your thanksgiving did
everybody have a good thanksgiving
if anyone has an interesting
thanksgiving story they want to share dm
zach or a b
how was your guys's thanksgiving to the
crew and the cast that was okay
it's pretty low key just made dinner at
home with the girl
yeah maybe yeah pretty much the same
here's how you guys did take out what
were you guys eating i saw in your insta
stories
something oh alina got some stuff from
costco but it kind of looked like take
out so
yeah costco i wish i thought of that we
were [ __ ] stuck with nothing you know
what minnie laid for thanksgiving you
know what our thanksgiving dinner was
mcdonald's drive-through was the only
[ __ ] amazing it was the only thing
open
no i mean i wanted better i couldn't
even find a pizza
order man like domino's was closed i was
like man
domino's no one's making a pie on
thanksgiving
wow ian talk to me baby
just relax just us you know some turkey
the works oh you went all out you're
kind of a chef right so you probably
cooked
not a lot but well sam's a great cook
though she knows what she's saying
that's
nice yeah she hooks it up
i'm putting on those quarantine pounds
with her around you know
ian are you still having sleepwalking
issues or is that kind of
calm down well i also want to say i feel
like every time we do
funny videos there's always comments
where people are like
is ian okay he seems really depressed
i just don't laugh i don't know it's i'm
hard to laugh that's hard to laugh so
maybe this show should be make
ian laugh that'll be really now that
actually would be depressing yeah
yeah it is kind of depressed like you
kind of i kind of feel like i have to
turn your camera off at times
because it's like i'm trying to be funny
and you know it's like when you're a
comic
you want to see people in the audience
laughing it gives you energy it gets you
hyped up but if everybody in the
audience is staring at you like this
yeah you kind of be like oh i'm bombing
so yeah i don't know
what's what i don't is that off-putting
somehow
the feeling that i'm bombing
tell me a joke so ian
tell me
tough crowd over here hi fred why are
you being so cute right now i'm trying
to do a show
what did you get for mcdonald's what was
on the menu
what's the code too well i always get
like a regular burger
not a regular burger you get the quarter
pounder with cheese bruh okay
that's the movie i don't know and um
coffee i love mcdonald's wait did i hear
correctly that mcdonald's dropped all
day breakfast
yeah so it actually it ruins my day
well no wait so many times i just want
the mcmuffin
that's so odd to me and everybody was
going hard
what is wrong with you guys wait i don't
think they dropped it they just went
back to morning only breakfast
yeah [ __ ] who is up before 11
at mcdonald's well i was getting i was
personally getting mcmuffins like
24 hours yes around the clock the one
thing to get every time
so everybody had a good thanksgiving
problems
zach how was yours yours sounded better
than mine i'll tell you that oh did you
see the family
no yeah yeah i went to um
well not that family i went down to go
see my grandmother in palm springs
and um you went down to see your grandma
aren't you worried about giving her
coved
well it was very distanced and we all
got tested
oh yeah how many people were there it
was just my
mom dad brother and then small gathering
yeah yeah yeah and uh yeah it was a good
time
woke up early and then drove back did
you get any [ __ ] for your comment in the
thanksgiving special about how you hate
your family
i did so at one of my uh extended
family's house
which my other grandmother was at but
you know my uncle and grandmother
they're like oh you know we're so proud
of zach
let's show him what you know what what
he does
and they put the clip of me just bashing
my [ __ ] family that's the
i wasn't referring to to that part of
the family
but that's just saying that because you
know they'll watch this
no it wasn't it wasn't that
part of the family i was referring to so
now the other part of the other half
right well [ __ ] they can go [ __ ]
themselves really
you're that openly and you're that
openly hostile
i am so openly hostile about that what
did they do to you what did they do to
you and your family
there is so much tell me something i
they are go ahead
diabolical tell me one thing they've
done
they're yeah man they're just
evil all right takers and uh they're
just not good people
they're not good they're not welcome at
your thanksgiving table unfortunately
they do not live
in los angeles would they be surprised
to hear you say this or would they be
like yeah
that's how you know that we've had total
blowouts with them
and it's always entertaining and yeah
i did not expect this is this on your
dad's side or your mom's side
this is on my dad's side i knew i knew
it i knew this was a todd related
yes yes indeedy yes indeedy but
quite honestly there
[Laughter]
i don't understand these inner family
beefs to be honest with you because my
mom had some pretty
uh strong beefs within her family and
yours too my dad's
family is all like that um and there's
they're so big and i don't know any of
them
that all i hear is just like this weird
like half stories i'm like oh this guy's
not talking to her so you're not gonna
see them together
or like oh yeah she can come because she
doesn't talk to this guy who's gonna be
there
for context ila has like 20 aunts and
uncles
oh wow yeah both of her parents have
like 10 siblings right 10 and 8.
yeah so
your family gathering is kind of like an
episode of mori or jerry
jerry springer or something
yeah but i i personally don't get it i
mean like it's family i feel like you
all should be able to resolve it just
bury the hatchet i've gotten some beef
with some of my family but it's like you
know what
i just got to bury this you know
but but maybe but maybe i've never been
wronged as bad as as
you guys have i mean there's certainly a
line that i i can imagine someone
crossing where i'd be like oh [ __ ] them
forever but maybe that just hasn't
happened
well well shout out to zach's despised
half of the family
evil oh my god dude
evil all right yeah
okay well if anyone has any interesting
thanksgiving stories go ahead
send them in i really want to deep fry a
turkey i've always wanted to do that
it looks tasty i've been seeing it on
tik tok it's like all i see on ticked
for some reason
and it just looks great i don't know did
you see videos of that they like
they have like a huge canister it's like
a
garbage can full of oil heated up to a
boil and you
drop the poor turkey sounds awful but
yeah i mean sure it's awful yeah has
have you guys ever had a deep-fried
turkey it looks so good
i did once is it good is it worth it it
was better than
than normal turkey okay that's all it
say no more
it's still not great also you know it's
super dangerous and i
i think yes every year like
50 people burn their houses down trying
to do it yeah well
i could tell it's super dangerous
because every person i saw on tick tock
is like out in the middle of the street
they've got like a glove that it looks
like you would handle plutonium with
yeah you know it's like suddenly slowly
pick it up
slowly yeah but i still want to do it
looks fun i'll skip it well you got to
be safe about it
um do you want to tell them about our
other
plans of uh not plans what we did oh
yeah me and eila got drunk
just the two of us it's funny um wow i
don't think we've done that in a decade
i was hungover this morning so we're
like okay oh that's why it took so long
we can get we can drink today tonight
let's just do it it's thanksgiving
there's nobody here we put theodore to
bed
we break out the vodka
i personally like the vodka and the soda
water on ice i don't [ __ ] around i don't
like the extra sugar
you know that's what gets you hungover
but i got i was i was hungover man i
woke up took some
tylenol drank a whole pint of water or
whatever a lot of water i woke up so
thirsty
ultimately it was fun but i really don't
like drinking that much
it was fun though no it was really fun
but then you i don't like wake up like
craving to do it again like
some drugs you're like oh that was so
fun i won't do that again yeah
because i really feel it
yeah the next day it was fun though we
watched bachelor like for 10 hours
bachelor nation ali has been watching it
this season seems
ridiculous it's great yeah it's
ridiculous it's awesome
okay so speaking of thanksgiving we've
got some thanksgiving memes
this i saw today uh demi
lovato it's awesome
so she's in this ad about humane
like a humane turkey ad which i've been
seeing a lot from peeta and stuff
uh who got meme done by the way i'll
show you guys that next turkeys are
bright social animals who enjoy being
pet
just ask demi lovato cut to demi
lovato's instagram
i'm thankful for you all
it's awesome isn't it
it's like oops did we forget about why
about this it's so funny
the only explanation is maybe she took a
picture with a turkey at some point and
then they used this
right but it's sponsored what are they
doing farm sanctuary
well she cooked that [ __ ] turkey
she's like hey hey
i didn't say just because i cooked it
doesn't mean it's not social and doesn't
like being pet
i would i like that turkey
you know that was those were the ways
you would be like i love my animal
and now i'm gonna eat it because it's
cold and i need food
here um here let me show you what pita
pita i understand the cause of veganism
like totally
but these guys really need to get their
[ __ ] together
they they put out this saying imagine if
you were the one being stuffed
for thanksgiving dinner and everybody
there was a lot of responses but it was
like yes dad he stuffed me daddy
or whatever you know
got him zach you can't you sound just
say it
don't sound bite yourself
[Laughter]
so if you did uh
what i guess it's like the neck you know
sometimes you take out the neck
stacked bro brah
um
you guys know that the butthole candle
sold out like i'm really proud of you
guys you guys sold out that candle
really fast man
and i kind of regretting not getting
more because it sold out like a day
then we only got like i thought it would
but you were scared that no one would
buy it
really yeah because it was expensive
with 75 bucks yeah but
and i didn't want to be stuck with like
a bunch of [ __ ] scented candles in
warehouse
yeah it's like oh [ __ ] good luck
unloading those
but we raised a bunch of money for
prostate uh cancer awareness so good job
everybody
we got articles oh yeah [ __ ] there
was articles about it that was the best
thing
lad bible you can buy a candle that
smells like a butthole this christmas
okay it's awesome
i can't wait that's what i was wondering
too
the people who made it i've never seen
this photo
sent it on instagram really where
here it says the other profits will go
to okay nice
credit h3h3 shop thank you man if i knew
this would be such a christmas
phenomenon i would about a hell of a lot
more i mean i want more people to see
this a lot of a lot of work and patience
and love went into this and butt holes
should we restock probably not it would
take too long
it remember it took a long time yeah
yeah although a lot of that was like the
research because there was actually
there was a lot of r d yeah did we get
into there
apparently the scent was uh it was too
powerful
and it was like uh it wasn't mixing
correctly with the wax and they had to
do all kinds of stuff to make it
actually work
there was a lot of people in the
laboratory with vials
smelling and re-smelling tinkering
you know skippy actually put out a
uh thanksgiving thank you
video that i was touched by i watched it
last night when i woke up
hungover at like 5am it's on my homepage
you know skippy
would have been home he would have
literally been homeless really
he basically he said thanks to you guys
he lost his job
he's yeah we got him fired no i'm
kidding he lost his job
he's being kicked out he has to be moved
out totally by monday
and so he was a he's got a storage
locker
that he's trying to put all of his [ __ ]
into by monday
and he's trying to find a place and he's
having a lot of trouble finding a place
because
he doesn't have credit and he doesn't
have a job but he's got some money in
the bank from
from us from the community i mean and uh
he's just expressing how thankfully his
because i think he would have been
homeless we've been homeless that's
crazy and it just makes me think
not like skippy's in our world and we
love and appreciate skipping we do
everything we can to help him but
so many people like him yeah just goes
to show you kind of how people come
homeless and just makes me sad that
we fail so to help so many people in
this world or because
i don't have a job and i don't have a
good credit
and for those two reasons i shouldn't
even have a chance at finding
a place soon but i do and i will because
of
ethan and gila and zach
and the h3h3 family zach got a shout out
so this is my uh thanksgiving day
thank you to all of you guys uh i
haven't made videos yet i've been
really looking for places and have been
trying to uh
both deal with that and anyway it's it's
a long video i recommend you guys watch
it but
all the cameos he's been getting lots of
cameos and i think that's just [ __ ]
great
so if you um i text him yesterday happy
thanksgiving and he's like the most
wholesome dude oh he got back with you
yeah he's also he's always like the
nicest texture he's all thanks zach
a bunch of hearts it's not traditional
but because of you guys i'm doing what i
need
in order to move forward happy
thanksgiving to you and yours
p.s whoever works at h3 that i keep
forgetting to think
yeah i mean the whole video he it's
thanksgiving thank you everyone
and he's at 5 a.m at the storage
facility
that's [ __ ] well i'm glad that you
know
i'm glad man i'm just happy that we were
able to help him yeah if you guys want
to continue to support skippy you know
where to find him on cameo
i am skippy let's go dude we gotta have
to do a call with him
check in with him once he's all settled
sure
you know um
i would love to hear more about ethan's
experience at the school in germany
which part of germany did he visit is
there anyone who met him at the
cool i went to
a high school in hamburg or not hamburg
north of hamburg a city called elmshorn
little town north of
palm bear cute little spot i loved it it
was nice i loved germany it was like
so how old were you it was 18 which was
crazy which was really cool because i
was legally allowed to drink there
yeah actually you can drink beer at 16
but i was you're able to buy
hard alcohol at 18. so i was like ben
pippen over there
and i never drank alcohol before so i
had my first beer ever
and i it was it was great we went to a
bar i had like two
beers and i was trying i was like trash
it's pretty wild at 18 to go for a full
month somewhere
on your own did you speak any german
yeah
you did yeah was that your foreign
language that you studied in high school
oh i studied german too i didn't know
that you took german all jews
oh careful dude what are you trying to
say at this point why would you bring
that up i'm talking about germany
freak um
yeah i stayed you have some wild stories
from there like uh
you had to um what was it to get back
yeah so so everybody
and i'm not complaining because the
family was really nice and i liked them
a lot
but everybody had like a normal house in
town
so i got just randomly assigned with
this girl
whose family lived out in a [ __ ] like
literal
barn in like the countryside so it was
like an hour bike ride
and my bike had like um
there was a light that was like powered
by the wheels motion so it made it like
harder to ride
and there's nights where i would go
there it would get dark really early and
i would ride out in the [ __ ]
countryside like children of the corn
[ __ ]
out into like this total barren
farmland that sounds crazy and so like
and then you would enter the house
through a sliding barn door
and they built me a room in the attic
because they didn't have space so they
they built your room they built me a
room that wasn't there before
in the attic so like my room was like
this you know it was like
yeah and like i had this i had to go up
into a crawl space and like duck down
and [ __ ]
it's like frank style and what
bro it wasn't a frame
i would and you know i was probably the
only jew that was going to
it's like why you gotta end frank
[Laughter]
so was it was it weird that it's like
a boy and a girl like was there
attention for you no cause i feel like
at that age
everyone's awkward no like somehow
somehow no there wasn't any tension or
anything like that
no it was totally fine it was totally
fine yeah
but the girl who was with my family and
bless her soul she was so nice i think
it's part of their rustic
upbringing she didn't wear deodorant
and so like she came the girl also came
to my house
mm-hmm for a month and stayed yeah
that's the exchange so
she came to our house for a month and
then the next summer i went to her house
for a month
wow but it wasn't just me there was like
a whole group like sean balog was with
me and garrett mats and like a lot of my
friends
so you spent a lot of time with this
girl like
i must have but i bare i
but she didn't wear uh deodorant and so
there were times where she was with my
family
hot you know los angeles summer and she
would get in a room with my family to go
do something and boy there was like a
it would stink up the whole [ __ ]
place and i'm not proud to admit it but
we called her not to her
i'm i don't say yeah yeah
yeah don't say it again
but anyway that's all i remember it's
just the rustic lifestyle that they used
to do
um but it was great you know
we went to the red light district we
were just like you know what i mean they
have like a red light
there's so much different about germany
that was like crazy to experience
you go down to downtown hamburg and then
you just go to the red light district
and there's literally prostitutes
behind a glass window it's so weird like
merchandise
yeah and you're just walking through the
street and there's just girls in
lingerie behind a glass window being
like you know
like come by me i'm you come [ __ ] me
none of us did but
maybe i should have i was scared i was
like ah
i was virgin i wasn't gonna lose i
didn't want to use my virginity some
[ __ ]
you know well it's all regulated frankly
to be to be totally honest
they were not that attractive either
weird i mean i would certainly be more
tempted
if i was attracted to them which i
wasn't
no but none of us did i think we're all
scared but we cruised through and just
saw what was going on and stuff it's fun
food was great you know the people were
super nice
very lush and green and beautiful that
was german that's what i remember
germany being
that's awesome yeah it was nice
duna duner keep up was what we [ __ ]
with
which was like a euro like a burrito
euro do not keep up
[ __ ] bomb five euro like forget about
it kebab
no it was like i shaved kabob it was
like shaved
yes turkish for sure anyway
uh i have a big announcement news coming
up for you zack
philadelphian announces she's gonna be
doing
internet oh did you is you cut the tits
out of this
i edited it yeah very good because she
shows her titties at the end
yeah sorry zach i'm sorry daddy did you
you saw the titties though right zach
had a thousand times oh my god earlier
let me watch this
hello internet so it's been really fun
playing with you over the last couple of
years but i think now is
finally the time that you've all been
waiting for
this year the 25th or december christmas
day
i'm going to be posting my hardcore
porn onto my only fans
and if you don't believe me well
so so she she went that whole time
without ever showing her titties
they were like the nipples were blurred
hmm so she
she showed her titties even for free on
on twitter
yeah man did you bust to that nah
it's a starter man it's it's like oh
okay so
you got the fire started with that
though
yeah they'd led to a session interesting
of course it did yeah thank you bye the
people
all of our members i forgot to say we
love our members they're the greatest
ever
true greatest that ever did it i'm gonna
bust to you guys
there's like a bite thank you thank you
it's like one
tiny nap
so what what do you expect to see what
is what does hardcore mean i mean it
could be a whole range of stuff for her
like is she gonna be taking a dick do
you think or like just like masturbating
but she always blurs
oh it's blurred yeah i mean hardcore
implies the whole thing yeah but she's
also a legendary troll
i mean i don't think she's crawling this
is the real deal she showed her titties
yeah so you think she's gonna be taking
one huh
oh yeah i mean that seems to be the
implication yeah oh yeah
so is her taking it would be like not
worthy right that's not warm up
no i mean that that's porn or that's
more hardcore
that's what that's what we're that's why
we're here it's penetration baby
that's all the way stop
yeah are you still seeing that girl that
i can't talk about
yes i am great good for you can i still
not talk about her
i mean i suppose you can oh what well
what changed did anything
because i don't want to get you in
trouble
hey b what is your take on this buddy
don't put don't put me between you guys
no no no no no no no no i want your take
a b can i talk about it because i don't
want to get him into
into deeper [ __ ] than he already is
saying that he wants to kill half his
family
i mean if he's okay with it i mean i
know we've talked about it privately i
just don't know if he wants to be that
open
we may be i would love to talk about it
okay i'll
i'll talk about it but what do your
parents know are they gonna find out
through this
i i told them okay good good okay
okay so how did they react so first of
all
tell the news who are you dating i'm
dating
an adult film star named buccaneer
what's her name jane wilde
is her name jane wilde yeah and how did
you guys uh connect
she messaged me on instagram damn
jane wilde message you is this her
is this her zach not stephen hawking's
wife is this her
i can't see you should come up in a
second yeah that's her
damn dude and so what kind of this did
she do like pornhub [ __ ] or did you have
only fans what did she do
yeah best of both worlds um very
successful in her craft
um so wait all this ass eating
and all this [ __ ] all this ass eating
and all this [ __ ] must have gotten
her interested right because i don't
think she would have messaged you
otherwise right
right but it was also like our bond
she's she's really cool she loves good
music
and like wow
just you know like not the fact that
she's a porn star it's
like you know she's a cool person
i gotta say not a lot of dudes are
comfortable with their girlfriend
[ __ ] other dudes for their craft
so it does you know i i look at it as a
job
yeah and um it doesn't bother me
now okay i have this is this is great i
i did this is
great this is fantastic this is why
we're here
so you guys met you talked in the dm she
messaged you what
what went down the show is like yes yes
yes it is
cool is she watching right now maybe yes
i think she is
maybe let's get her lined up to call in
can we get her lined up to call in a b
while i talk to zach
he has to be a member
yeah so okay we gotta do that okay so
anyway if
if she's out there message a b because i
want to talk to zach
so she messaged you what'd she say what
was that conversation like
she's like saw my you know instagram
videos and
um she's like you're an amazing guitar
player
oh that's the way to your heart huh we
should grab dinner
and um yeah
and so how long before messaging
did you guys meet up in person she lives
nearby you yes
yeah and you guys went to dinner did you
guys [ __ ] on the first date
no we did not you didn't no how long
before you guys had sex
before talking um
or since talking uh it was
probably a
week or so oh a week that's pretty good
and how and how was the first sexual
encounter were you nervous because
that's a
because this is an experienced girl she
knows her way around
you know she's got all the tricks of the
trade were you were you nervous
um
i don't necessarily want to talk about
that oh
yeah if that's all right but no i was
not nervous
really yeah no so you don't want to talk
about intimate details of your sex life
right now that
pretty much strikes away 70 percent of
the questions i had
okay can i just ask you this have you
eaten her ass
[Laughter]
well you know at least let me ask that
after all the talk
sure yeah sure i mean we all assumed yes
after a hike now that we've had this
extremely explicit conversation um
it is 30 minutes we should probably do
our ass okay
zach well okay let's do the ads and i'll
come back to you
how did your parents react though like
when you told them because i know when i
when you first told me i was like holy
[ __ ]
but you're like my parents don't know
they didn't they were really
you know skeptical of this relationship
and
you told him that that you weren't gonna
date her so how did that play out
um i mean it's fine i mean
she's i'm i'm looking forward for them
to meet her
and oh family intro yeah
no she's really cool she's a good person
so this sounds like a really serious
thing well i mean
i mean you guys are you guys are dating
yeah yeah
yeah you consider yourself her boyfriend
sure yeah are you are you hesitating
because you're worried or
about uh well it's early yeah it's early
she's probably watching this
conversation
is your hesitancy that you don't want to
become you don't want to be over eager
and be like hey i'm your boy i'm the
boyfriend
i'm just i'm i'm going with the flow and
that's how i'm
rolling with it right i'm a happy face
zach
yeah thank you that's awesome
i mean who better for zach than a porn
star
that's great do you ever watch her porn
when you're jerking off
no really i kind of put the reins on
that but i know who she was before
you started talking wait what do you
mean you put the reins on it you don't
like watching her work
i mean not with another dude oh it makes
you feel comfortable
i wouldn't get off to that you know it
just it makes you uncomfortable to see
her
like having sex with someone else
i wouldn't say uncomfortable it's just
not my cup of tea i'm not like a
like a cuckold you know like um wait
well
interesting so all of a sudden straight
normal porn turns into
in your mind cuck porn well no no it
would just be like me singer with
another dude
that what do you why can't i talk why
i don't look at the chat first of all
when i'm doing the show i don't let
people get my head
and why the [ __ ] am i not allowed to ask
zack of these questions why does it make
people
so what this is the thing i asked he
asked kenny can he
talk about it that gave him permission i
mean this is
what happens this is the conversation we
have is no one else curious about these
things
this is [ __ ] gold i don't understand
why is everyone trying to put the kibosh
on this conversation
nobody else no one's putting i'm curious
i think a lot of people what the [ __ ]
why is everyone freaking out
who's putting the kybosh on it dan's
going stop and everyone in the chat's
going stop it's like the minute and i
start talking to skippy about
his masturbation practice everyone has a
[ __ ] mental breakdown it's like
that's interesting skippy jerking off
is interesting this is a guy whose
bishop told him that if you touch
yourself you have to confess every time
this is a guy who's now jerking off the
virgin of 40 years old
i want to know about that nobody else
does i mean what the [ __ ] is going on
here am i crazy
this is the show it's after dark
why are people telling me to stop
no they're saying don't stop yeah
exactly don't stop i just
like you made a good pitch it's okay if
it gets a little uncomfortable
i mean it's interesting i think god damn
but yeah i think i think as time goes on
i'll be
more open about it it's a fresh
relationship
yeah yeah yeah
will she call in will you message text
her and see if she'll call in
or do you not want that i mean what
would you wouldn't
even want to ask her i don't know let's
find out
you can message me on instagram if she
wants i don't know how to get hold of
all right let me do an ad while we
figure this out
stop zach hit the sound you got to hit
the stop sound bite on your stop
yeah i got it i got that one on the
speed dial over here
stop jesus stop talking get into the
interesting [ __ ]
screaming stop all right what do we got
here
harry's yeah harry's
razors we love harry's razors because
it gives you that close shave that
smooth
glide it's that conveniently low price
they ship it right to your door it's
harry's razor
should be called hairless racer
because it makes your ass hairless you
know
new customers can redeem a harry's trial
set of harry's by going to harrys.com
h3 you get everything you need for just
three bucks
you know harry's got that honest value
they were founded by two friends
who were tired of overpaying for razors
they thought that most big brands were
over designed overpriced and out of
touch
so they founded harry's as a return to
the essential
quality blades at an honest price as low
as two dollars per refill
they've got that quality german
engineered blades
harry's founder wants to sell products
they'd be proud of so they raised a
bunch of money to buy
razor factory germany they've been
honing precision razor blades for 1
billion years it says 100 but
they sourced their steel from sweden and
owned the entire manufacturing product
process from r d to the factory floor
this allows them to keep the prices low
elo
there's a big difference between a good
blade and bad blade there's some really
shitty blades out there yeah use the
blade to shave your leg right
right you ever use a really shitty blade
and be like [ __ ] this yeah
yeah not harry's though
harry's makes you hairless would you say
yeah why isn't that the slogan
i don't know i love that they chose the
name harry's though even though it's not
any of their names like the founders
yeah i think it's
yeah i like it too it's a good name
good choice should we get chinese food
tonight
no not now's not the time
thinking about food no okay let's think
about razors
new sharper blades harry's is delivering
the sharpest shave ever
and they are not raising prices that's
what good guys those mother
lovers are their new blades are so sharp
that guy
shaving four times per week report that
with their new blades their eighth shave
was
just as smooth as their first also
they're so confident
they stand by their blades with a 100
money back guarantee
at harry's.com harry's is now available
wherever you shop
we've got a great offer oftener we've
got a great offer for our listeners
new us customers can redeem harry's
trial set at harry's dot com slash h3
for just
three freaking dollars you'll get five
bl a five blade razor
a weighted ergonomic handle foaming
shave gel with aloe
aloe aloe i got it right this time and a
travel cover to protect your blade when
you're on the go that's just three bucks
what the
[ __ ] just go to harrys.com
h3 and redeem your trial offer today
thank you to harry's
did you get a hold of her zach is she
interested
yeah she is fantastic i can't be the
only one that wants that
no i don't care what you guys want it's
my [ __ ] show it's like
i can't listen to you guys i gotta do
the show how i want
like obviously you guys gotta trust me a
little bit to make an entertaining show
right
apparently not apparently i don't know
if i trust myself at this point
which isn't good guys you need a captain
that's willing to drive the ship
and make decisions for the show you know
you can't have me under
i'm minding myself sorry
oh that reminds me we got cigarettes
last night it was pretty funny
i couldn't get cigarettes i was on post
mates i was on doordash we were drunk i
just wanted to pack cigarettes
and so we ordered a bunch of [ __ ] from
7-eleven the guy
i couldn't there used to be a postmates
a field that you could enter a custom
order and for some reason they got rid
of that
and it's not like a weird thing they
sell alcohol on postmates
and it was and i even looked it up it's
legal to sell tobacco products on
postmates
so the guy shows up at my house with all
the snacks and stuff we got and i said
bro
by the way this is thanksgiving evening
at like 11.
so i says bro can you go down the street
and get me a pack of cigarettes like
i'll give you
40 bucks just it's like five minutes
down the road
he's like yeah of course so he comes
back
uh he takes 20 to buy the six he comes
back
and then he's like i gave him another 20
i was like thank you so much it was five
minutes down the street
and he's like oh this is awesome this is
my first night uh
delivering so this is great and i was i
was super drunk at the time
and i was like bro you're the man i i
don't know if there's a puff piece for
myself but it was funny
i feel like this is like a papa john you
know when he's like big
take it yeah but i thought but you were
laughing i thought it was a funny story
because i was super drunk outside and i
just emptied my wallet i gave him a
hundred bucks i was like
god bless you bro his name was saeed
i mean it was thanksgiving i was like
this guy's out at 11
at thanksgiving i couldn't i was about
to message a b i was getting so
desperate i'm sorry i didn't though
i'm glad i didn't because i know you
would have done it and i've heard that
yeah i was i planned on doing it i was
going to surprise you
no i'm glad i didn't mess with you it's
got to be boundaries
i'm going to do it i know you would
that's why i didn't want to mess with
you
so anyway syed hooked it up and i was
super stoked was how you did that for me
okay ridge wallet we love ridge you want
to don't smoke though and we don't
promote smoking of course not
smoke weed every day not weed we don't
promote any kind
any form of smoke consumption guys
it's ridge wallet it's slick it's hot
it's compact it's it's basically can
endure a nuclear blast
it has a lifetime guarantee warranty
they say this wallet will last you
forever
if anything happens to it we'll refund
you lifetime guarantee
i wonder if we should do some kind of
test no it didn't break that thing is
indestructible it felt through the
vortex
and disappeared
i'd like to do a crash test with it and
like see how durable it is like
go to a shooting range i feel like this
thing could take a bullet
that's that's a good ad like i really do
they don't pay me enough for that yeah
if you guys are listening they should
make that ad
maybe i'll ask them come on guys let's
let's step this partnership up
anyway i love it because i'm tired of
lugging around these huge ancient
wallets
look the times have changed all you need
is credit cards
and some cash right and that's what this
is all about it holds up to 12 cards
in this little compartment here i don't
know if you could see
it just they slide in and they slide out
and then there's a cache clip
okay i mean you don't need anything more
than that and that's what's the beauty
of it you slide in your pocket and
you're good to go
and for the ladies small purses are
really
in right now true for some reason by the
way they're making like tiny purses and
i don't know what
do you not even put anything in it
anymore it's just an accessory
i don't know i like them though they're
cute look at all these cool styles while
i've come to the point where my wallet
just doesn't fit in anyway
so you kind of have to go on this this
one's sick
topograph topographic sick
yeah they've got a ton of really cool
designs they have some cool ones for
girls too like the rose gold i love the
rose gold
and it's just a great product i mean
what can i say
holds up to 12 cards there's 30 colors
and styles
they have 30 000 5 star reviews it comes
with a lifetime warranty you could buy
one wall and carry it for life
and they'll even let you buy it own it
for 45 days and if you don't love it
send it back for a full refund i mean
come on
come on get it get it
and you'll get 10 off today with free
worldwide shipping
and returns by going to ridge.com h3
and use the code h3 link is in the
description
thank you all all right so we have this
where are we talking or are we moving on
uh
zach we're setting it up right now just
little technical difficulties
yeah so in the meantime
how's this sucks can i ask that too
early
no too early okay don't answer it's got
to be good
yeah yes
yeah right that's what i mean it's like
it's like dating a uh
a major league baseball player and being
like how's his uh swing
it's good even if he's not a good batter
he's got a good swing you can guarantee
that
you know what i mean how's his jump shot
it's good he's a pro no
3 500 baby does she do like mainstream
porn or does she like
like she works for like the big brands
and stuff
yeah so she's got a pretty yeah
she works for the big names but also has
like
a contract with a big company i don't
know if it's
contract um
i don't know that the business side of
that aspect
but um yeah she does very well it's
awesome
yeah zach maybe um you could take a
minute and
explain to her how to do it because
she's in the call-in but she's not
talking
the lobby all right i'll call it so in
the meantime there's
actually a weird theory that zach is the
male talent and bells
uh premiering her only fans
so oh it has this has zero points guys i
don't find this very
oh so apparently i heard there was a
very compelling
but it doesn't look very compelling
in four days very not compelling i've
been wondering non-stop about this
comment that ethan made
on after dark and i'm here to put forth
my final hypothesis
zach is the male talent in the upcoming
yeah zach
bro can you imagine i know this is crazy
but hear me out
so apparently here is uh some kind of
evidence let's see
okay well okay that's the elect what
wait this it says 8 23. i hate watching
ourselves
okay i hate watching myself
i see you know
zach was wondering if you've ever been
to black
and i actually asked you know we're all
thinking it here
exactly you're well hey we're all
thinking
here yes we are well
it doesn't seem very compelling what
what
guys did anyone read this i mean
conclusion i know this is crazy and
improbable but i would rather be the guy
who guessed correctly
bro that's that's dumb it's like you can
just make any outlandish prediction
about anything and then bit
if you're wrong you just forget it and
if you're right you'll be like i'm a
prophet
in the doc there's a time stamp it came
from whenever
you were asking zack to talk about it
and me and dan were like don't do it
yeah whatever your theory sucks bro
yeah i think it was based off of him not
wanting to talk about what we're talking
about right now
okay he's in love with peace and love oh
interesting
with peace and love your theory sucks
bruh let's just say not compelling
um herbie and yeah
you guys want to watch some good [ __ ]
old guy drops a [ __ ] in the middle oh we
have a new guy shooting on the floor
video
that's awesome dude oh my god there's so
many of these on the internet
oh it's always kind of oh bro all the
way down to long pants huh
wait have we seen this one i don't think
i've seen this
oh dude that's not the first time that
guy's done that
that was like a pro move
he's an old guy so i guess it's like a
condition probably
yeah but wear diapers yeah we're a
diaper don't leave a
human dookie on the floor in a subway it
looks like
yeah bro this is not the first guy he's
not even wearing underwear as far as i
could tell
i guess he's gonna be able to be like on
the go like
but let it slide all the way
i don't think we've ever seen someone
with long pants do this
so let's watch this one more time
right down the pant leg and we're on the
move i mean you know what that reminds
me of shawshank redemption
when he would bring the sand out
and empty it through yeah
this guy's a pro man he got in and out
nobody suspected a damn thing
i kept i'm sorry
i have jane on the line sorry there's a
little light okay great what's her name
gina
jane jane jane jane jane jane jane are
you there
hello
hello i kind of hear you guys but also
not really jane jane jane
jane no it just sounds like
like muffled um it's probably
that's probably not on our end right dan
i would imagine not so we tested discord
right before the show
jane jane jane jane jane
all right hello yeah hi jane we hear you
fine
yeah we're hearing you fine all right
let's let's continue the pooping uh
why don't you talk to her ab and discord
until she so she can resolve that or
zack whoever okay i know you're saying
something
but i can't understand what you're
saying so you can just move her into a
private room
i got it yeah cool so props to this guy
i wonder how long it takes to
is that do you think that's oh so damn
someone's gonna step in it i love how
they fast forward to someone stepping in
it
and they're all you know you know
they're smelling it
i didn't think she stepped in it yeah
here he comes here he comes
here he comes no no whoa whoa whoa wait
he wasn't even close
oh dude what is wrong with you man
[ __ ] me that just makes me think like
this is this phenomenon has got to be
happening so many times
because we already saw it a lot by now
on video many times
yeah i've never seen [ __ ] in the wild no
but
based on this um what does that guy do
like what's his life like you know what
i mean
like what is his life like a person who
could do such a thing
she's just old are you controlling my
computer down
yeah i'm just checking something dan my
computer doesn't say anything
such a hacker how is it subtle i'm
watching a video
you're literally interrupting the show i
can't do anything
oh was it our mistake i'm just trying
something to see
jane jane jane okay
so um
probably stinky little tunnel no
ventilation
was the title of the video before
they're laughing at the title of the
video was that was that your edition
or was it fatty
fatty it was the reddit oh they're ready
fatty i was wondering well okay
yeah i don't need to watch that video a
billion times i could though trust me
all right what happens here
he's trying to kill a bug oh dude
this that has turkish uh fire yeah
why would you yeah why did you put the
canister so close to the damn fire
people really don't respect fire i gotta
say it's like
[ __ ] is scary you gotta be careful when
you're [ __ ] with fire
he knows what i felt like like why would
you put the canister so close man
you should be more scared than you are
i don't know how his hair caught on fire
but it did
oh jesus he seems fine i don't know
about his house though may have burnt
down
guys respect fire i mean really
you know
our zoom here is frozen but i guess
everything is fine
oh our zoom is frozen but that's fine
right
oh the one on the left is real i think
no
the middle one is the string is the chat
saying it's frozen
not
so what are they doing they're in a
haunted house it's like an escape room
they're yeah one of those kind of things
okay he's trying to keep his girlfriend
safe
yes
that gives me joy dude that's george
costanza vibes for sure
what a [ __ ] chivalrous dude
why does he keep slamming her in every
wall
he slams her into every wall oh my god
what is this
oh there was like some creepy ass chucky
following them
what dude leave your poor
she should be more scared of him than
the damn chunky dog
i would never do anything like that
that's so terrifying i would definitely
i would be bombing you and [ __ ] when
you're on the floor i'd be like [ __ ]
take her oh my god oh i gotta watch that
again
yeah let me do this in slow motion
because a lot happen
and i really want to enjoy everything
i'm seeing
let's put it into like half speed okay
so
so they're in a room some spooky [ __ ]
here let me mute it some spooky [ __ ]
comes at him looking like a chucky doll
and so here's the girl oh the girl
bro what wait he was like me first that
was a total like
hold on she's super scared she's in his
arms
he pushes her out of the way into the
wall
oh he brings her with him though he's
like come on yeah i think he's like
thinking he's just carrying her but
oh he left her that he she lost her shoe
oh my god
wait he closed the door on her no this
is them
they're on the cutting block they got
left behind
oh he's like don't go that way well okay
he's trying to help her he's like that's
a dead end don't go that way
right but she fit dude she got seriously
injured from this
how are you so scared dude they're in
pitch black and there's some clown ass
spook crawling towards them i'm not
doing this
i would be chatting too he's like nope
oh dude there's like our
oh that's the spooky clown he's right
behind you
oh god i mean you've played those crazy
this is like a
like a horror scene from a video game
but you're actually there
yeah but he to be that scared that
you're gonna
hurt her and everything oh for sure it
happens like you know it's
a game still yeah but what if it's not
you ever think about that our bruises
are real so here they come into this
room
oh what dude
oh do you see how spooky that is how
creepy that [ __ ] is look
i'm not hanging around with this [ __ ]
look at him
but it's like one of those setup
situations i underst
yeah it is no it's not real murder but
like damned
it's not that creepy people get ready
he's literally drag dolling her
[Laughter]
[Music]
i i was a monster for a couple years at
uh
at six flags doing this
it's honestly probably the most fun i've
ever had in my entire life
and people do freak out that because you
have ultimate power and they are
ultimately powerless it's
absolutely insane how much fun it is and
they probably [ __ ] like do you have any
any stories about people who really [ __ ]
the bed oh
i mean nothing as severe as that
but that is a really common thing of
like a dude
throwing their girlfriend between them
so relationships get broken there yeah
yeah
i like to think i wouldn't do that but
in the crisis of the moment eli might
sacrifice you
let's not think about it because
that's not a good one the adrenaline can
sing you're not they're not thinking
about it i'm just saying i'd like to
think that i would be the man and
then throw myself between you and the
monster but
just saying [ __ ] happens
well let's not think about it like i
said
i'd be like no i don't i don't even have
a doubt in me
i know that i would save you he was
trying to save her
he was he was trying to save her she was
just slacking behind it was just
you know he was trying to save her oh i
would definitely try to save you it's
just
you know maybe not i just know that
maybe not two people are getting out
here alive
you know
i'm kidding come on you know i would say
i'd [ __ ] go to war i dropped k i
would body
i would do that running drop kick with
two bags just take them out so you could
escape
i did almost get into fights a couple
times yeah i was wondering if anyone
ever gets
injured on the crew of the spooks yeah i
got punched a couple times not like
not in the face or anything but you know
just like a reaction yeah kind of thing
yeah and you know you can when people do
that it's like all right well
but some people would get really
aggressive and
uh you'd have to bounce them out of the
park yeah that's not you personally but
you would go to security and be like
this guy's got to go because he's like
trying to like beat up the clowns or
whatever you probably have kids who are
like
trying to act all tough they're like
what i'm not scared of you or whatever
did that happen
uh yeah big time yeah they ruined the
fun probably
here i this just what it looked like
i got to see this oh
dude that's badass that's great how long
it take to get that all ready
hours wow it was like two hours of
makeup
dude that's awesome so what so what was
the situation you were
like what was your station i guess well
in one one the first year that i did it
i was just in a haunted house thing like
that but then the second year which
this was a picture of i was just they
call them uh
[ __ ] what was the term for it i forget i
basically just wandered the park
like okay and the main part of the park
which was actually way more fun because
when you're in a haunted house
you like you said you have like a
station and kind of an assignment or
whatever
but the park walkers it's just like
freeform they're just
they give you kind of a big area of the
park and then like just stay in this
general area and
just go wild and and so do you hide you
just
run at people like i did a combination
of things i i
if you've ever been to any of those
parks they have the people that um
they have like knee pads and you slide
around on the ground and pick up sparks
or whatever that that's what i did
what you had knee pads yeah and you
picked up spark and like metal
things like fingers and [ __ ] and yeah it
was
and so i would just like charge at
people full speed and then slide on the
ground with a bunch of like fire kicking
up off of me with holy [ __ ]
i'll scare the [ __ ] out of people it's
so fun even tough guys
the chat said my brother used to work in
a haunted maze and he told me stories
about guys
throwing their girlfriends oh my god
do you really ruin your relationship i
don't think you can salvage that
like that would ruin the relationship
yeah no i agree i'm kidding i wouldn't
do that and i agree that that would
there's no salvaging that there's no
salvaging that
i wouldn't do that
i know in my heart i know my heart
[Laughter]
i would probably just hold you close and
just expect us both to die
you know what i mean that's i have no
problem we would die together
yeah but i wouldn't sacrifice you
yeah i'm pretty sure together yeah
that's so cool were you ever scared of
any other people there
me like the other people that were
scared maybe they'll come up and spook
your ass and then you're like oh
[ __ ] no when you're in that makeup you
feel very
uh like untouchable yeah and like kind
of like
i don't know disconnected from because i
i i get really scared when i go to these
things
yeah i don't like doing it but being on
the other side i can't deal with it
no i can't go yeah yeah i'm not really a
fan of
going to haunted houses but working was
fun as [ __ ]
all i know is when we shot the cancelled
episode of
scare pewdiepie oh yeah i just
remembered that and it was so
not scary that wasn't what that is but
that's not what it is
this is just when we did scare pewdiepie
it was like a bunch of zombies
in character but you're on set so it's
like okay and go
and you're like scared ah
but like a haunted house is scary as a
mother
yeah different five totally
they're like okay and
that was so action it was very dumb
no it's crazy it is crazy no no no i
mean it wasn't
i i thought it would be a really fun
episode i mean yeah the thing is
it was crazy i god i forgot i remember
when i was stuck on that building and i
had the [ __ ]
thing [ __ ] that was scary
i was on top of this building and he was
supposed to come rescue me
i think we even told the story but yeah
but i forgot in a while i'll just tell
the reader's digest and i had an earwig
like an earpiece that was broken it
didn't work so i was unable to
communicate
and this thing got jammed in my ear and
i couldn't get it out and i was just
up there panicking for hours while they
were getting ready
up there by myself and i was like ah and
my ears started bleeding
and it was stuck and i couldn't get it
out and i was like i had the lava on i
was like hey sound guy can you call the
medic
and i couldn't i couldn't hear them back
so but nobody was responding to me
and so when the scene was done and i got
down i was like yo bro i went to the
sound guy i was like did you [ __ ]
hear me freaking out
he's like yeah but i'm that's not my
department oh my god are you kidding me
yeah that's not my department what an
[ __ ]
and so they had to call medic to come
pull it out with tweezers
it was horrible yeah yeah
it was a big budget though i'm surprised
they can that whole [ __ ] thing
it's a huge budget man must have spent
millions on that episode alone
was that in the uh in the midst of his
uh
yeah cancellation from disney yeah
the whole second season got canned wow
crazy
yeah it was a big they had like there
was like probably you know
50 zombie actors a whole crew they built
this whole big
set with those pyrotechnics and a huge
zip line that they built and
i mean it was quite a [ __ ] production
that they canceled
but it was not scary in the least bit
you know the most [ __ ] up thing is
they get there was this one part where
they gave us shoes to wear with metal on
the bottom
oh yeah and then when we [ __ ] up they
would elect chicuda electric
electric electrocutos electrocute
yeah yeah and it was felt a little bit
[ __ ] up because
let me tell you that did not feel good
they gave they put [ __ ] on the bottom of
our shoes and zapped our ass yeah that
was pretty wild
and i think they realized that it was
too much and they kind of like
they stopped they they kind of just
stopped because they're like i
don't want to kill them
they paid me a thousand dollars for that
[ __ ] i remember what was that screamed
sound drop that you just played
is that a goat that's a a goat a ghost
cream
do we have a jane are we just moving
past that no i don't think we're going
to move past it yeah
okay i can figure it out also i was just
to clarify
i was trying to get her in and i and i
had you turned down when you were
talking about getting the cigarettes i
thought you were talking about a
playstation
so that's why the oil didn't surprise
you oh you got a playstation for me
no no i was trying to get me and we're
talking about trying to get one but uh
oh if you guys got one i'd [ __ ] i'd
rather pay you i'll pay you guys dude i
don't want to pay a scalper but i'll pay
you guys i'll put a bounty on that [ __ ]
yeah we'll give you guys a little right
now free finders
dude right now the ps5s are going for a
thousand dollars on stockx
but i'm not gonna pay these scalpers and
i'm the one that's put in a really
uncomfortable situation because that's
the only thing ethan wants christmas
um he doesn't care about anything i
can't buy him gift single gift for my
aunt
he doesn't care about shoes he doesn't
care about clothing like i've never
known anyone that doesn't care about
anything i have everything except the
playstation 5.
and i've been trying to get him the
playstation 5
it's like the mission impossible
they're on stockx but it's like a
thousand dollars no
it's not it's just it's the principles
that these [ __ ]
[ __ ] have these bots there's all
these people waiting in line
they're desperate people who want this
[ __ ] playstation can't get it and by
the way [ __ ] you
sony i don't know it's just ridiculous
and so
i saw a bot there's a guy who's using
bots to circumvent all these
digital lines he had like 3 500
playstations
he has more playstations than walmart
you know what i mean 3 500
yeah and so i he i don't know they have
these bots that pass
they [ __ ] cheat the line they're
automatic right like me and you we're
human beings they have bots that are
scanning these all these websites always
in
in perpetuity and as soon as they go
online they buy them all
and it's just it's outrageous and so
they're going for a thousand dollars
online i want the digital version it's
only 400 bucks and just on principle i
don't want to support them
i pray to god that a bunch of inventory
floods the market and these guys just
have to sell it at
retail or below stupid [ __ ]
so have you had like dreams about like
getting the playstation
no wanting something so bad not that
serious
but i was just gonna say if one of you
guys get it i will pay you a thousand
dollars
on principle i'm happy to pay it
but i don't want to give it to these
guys right
i'd want to just get it as a gift for
you well if you do then i'll [ __ ]
the one that's fair because you're a
better gift than me
oh i don't you think you can get it i
mean you haven't even got yourselves one
how are you gonna get me one well the
first day ian said let's go he's like oh
there shouldn't be a line
and then i got there before him and
there was like 20 people there
and they only had like thanksgiving oh
you were so close to getting one
i was really close to getting one on of
all places there was like
the sony website no yeah the sony
website i was so
close oh my god they had a digital line
i spent the whole evening on that stupid
website so stupid
they make you wait for an hour and so
people are virtual
waiting lines people have figured out
how to cut the line yeah you know
great so but also once your turn comes
then you realize you got to make an
account so stupid to buy it
like making an account took me an hour
it's insane well
the first time i got through and then
and then i had to i didn't know you had
to be signed in so when i tried to sign
in it
left the queue yeah and then i made an
account and it was too late
but then i was waiting again and then
the line was all buggy
ian what was the one that you got really
close to buying one or was that you dan
uh i i got really close what was that
website i'm [ __ ] walmart that's the
places oh walmart
yeah i got it into my cart and checking
out and and got all the way to paying
and it was like payment processing and
then it kicked me out and said
i just like like you could not me and
you were
in there we couldn't have been any
faster i don't know who's getting it
someone what you saying is in turkey and
people they are
getting it easily they're all region
locked though
i don't think you can use one from
overseas
like no but it's like why is it so
difficult oh right
yeah i think it's just the bots i really
do i think that like
thanks i think there's an artificial i
think a lot of people want it obviously
gotta be a shortage but why
i think there's just a huge demand for
the ps5 i get it
but i think the fact that bots are
buying like thousands potentially tens
of thousands of them are creating an
artificial
scale scarcity yeah
and what do you have to say about this
topic
i almost got one the other night too i
was i was awake like trying
like 2 30 in the morning and i randomly
checked twitter
and that that minute it went bestbuy
just put up
playstations randomly no announcement
and i had it in my cart put in your
payment information my
card was in my car oh i parked it like
two blocks away
so i literally in my boxers
ran down the street at 2 30 to get my
debit card oh [ __ ] in your neighborhood
dude
i'm scared i punched it in and then
they're like oh it's too late
it's definitely the bots i don't think
it's the boss it is like
they have they bent they're spent
they're selling it for so much more
it benefits them to just remove them
just buy everything
they're selling them for a thousand
dollars a pop they cost 400.
no way well who the [ __ ] is up at 238
this is a huge launch for sony they're
missing out on a lot of money i think
it's a [ __ ] cop i don't think this is i
agree it's a [ __ ] up but i also position
i think it's a both a [ __ ] up
and that these scalpers are ruining the
market
i'm telling you these scaffolders have
thousands and thousands of playstation
5s
yeah that's nothing they they're ready
to sell millions
you understand the scope of like yeah
fps no i do
and it's like best buy is releasing like
i agree there's not enough on the market
but
i don't know what's going on it's really
annoying
yeah people are using one of those bots
now because stuff like supreme and
yeast right they're more used to using
it so i'm not using one of those bots
i'm not
[ __ ] stumped oh you kidding man
just it's like damn it's like dude i got
i got money that's good why i gotta beg
and [ __ ] fight and to give you my
money it's like my money's good like
[ __ ] you like buying it's not enough i
need to give you my time
i need to give you my soul i need to beg
you to
please give me the the privilege of
buying your product
[ __ ] you
it's [ __ ]
i mean you know [ __ ] that but all of us
here are trying to buy it and none of us
have got it so
you know what i mean i'm gonna get it
i'm gonna get it for ethan are you gonna
get it for yourself for ethan
well don't give it to me you get it for
yourself first 1000 bucks
yeah i'll give you a thousand bucks if
you get it but that's to say there's got
to be a time limit on because at a
certain point it just can become
commonplace
right i got a ps4 that i never use you
want that
zach what the [ __ ] why would anyone want
that
garbage
[Laughter]
let's do some donations oh yeah i just
want to say
theodore gives me crazy baby fever you
guys are
the cutest kid me and my husband love
your podcast and tell you fresh
thank you he gives us babies yeah we're
trying because he's so cute
we're like we want another one another
one
you see uh one somebody donated 10 bucks
said one scalping group got 3 500 units
that's what i said yeah
okay yeah 3 500 units it benefits them
to clean them
the to clean it out because
but that's they're making more money
100 units is nothing they're making
millions of them yeah but there's a
bunch of people doing it this is just
one group
i don't know i mean i know that the bots
is an issue i just think that i agree i
don't know how there's not more
playstations out
but i'm assuming there's there's just a
lot that are when there's these queues
and everybody's lying to buy there's
bots that are buying it up first
you know the brand philadelphia that
makes like cream cheese
yeah they put out like a cream cheese
themed playstation
um that's a tub
a tub of cream cheese shaped like the
ps5
really and i was like no that'd be kind
of funny to buy and i went to the site
and it was sold out
like do i need bots to buy [ __ ] cream
cheese
now so it's not a playstation it's just
cream cheese
it's crazy yeah it looks like a place
kind of great but why feel it they'll
feel like that's what are you gonna do
with all that cream cheese
i love cream cheese zach shut up [ __ ]
you up
saying that
what's your extent of cream cheese like
we dip like pretzels and cream cheese is
everything to me
what what is this super weird this is
odd
philly series 5. so what exactly is this
what is i think that's the package you'd
lift the top and then there's cream
cheese
disgusting funny thing is this is gonna
be worth more
in the future it's fine just a bunch of
rotten cream cheese inside dude you got
the philly series 5.
[Laughter]
so dumb no i don't want that i want a
playstation
if i get the cream cheese before the
playstation would be pissed
can you become a little more
materialistic like so we can get you
gifts like normal people
what the [ __ ] i don't want to buy [ __ ] i
know i never this thing when i buy
clothes nice clothes and shoes
i never use it so it's like i knock i
don't want more [ __ ] than i'm gonna you
know what i'm gonna use a playstation
every [ __ ] night don't need any more
[ __ ]
i don't like [ __ ] i don't want [ __ ]
whatever
i don't want more [ __ ] my british accent
i told you to talk to me nice ethan
oh what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] you guys come on you gotta
be careful that poor girl
so they show her ass and then they're
like whoops
face plant
[Music]
damn you gotta be careful poor girl in
her wedding
jeez louise oh my god you can't be doing
that to the girl on her wedding day and
that's unforgivable
does that upset you it subs upsets me
because it's like something like that
just ruins the day
her vibe is gonna be [ __ ] all night
now yeah
yeah oh my lord
he blew it
oh let me see this this is this the one
oh no
bro what are you doing guys do not
go to a chiropractor that's a
chiropractor i don't know
i don't hopefully why does he have a
gloves like it's going to kill her
jesus christ
what the [ __ ] look he's tapping her on
the back like they're there now you'll
be fine
watch how he treats her afterwards
just watch how he's like that's what i
meant to do i can't
wait watch it watch how he reacts to
ruining her back
watch this he's like there there you're
okay
[Music]
my god
oh my god
bro let's watch this
let's put that in slow motion
[Music]
so this guy i'm sure considers himself a
chiropractor
bro you pulled her head down so hard
and you know what's [ __ ] up is that
looks like he's trying to kill her it's
like he's just a really shitty assassin
you know what's [ __ ] up is that you
know she already has back pain that's
why he's there
dude look how bad of an assassin he is
[Applause]
oh i feel so bad for that poor woman
[Music]
hmm
wow sister schnapped
oh geez dude i don't know if that one
will ever be the same
i don't think that one will ever be the
same after that ian
yeah i know not even his money he's not
even amused
he didn't see it he was he was going to
the bathroom he saw it
no i just saw him oh my god that too he
saw enough to laugh
he was here for the sisters snapped bro
i'm just being dead seriously guys
chiropractors
this is i know this guy's probably not
licensed
but this is the type of [ __ ] these
[ __ ] get up to dude
their chiropractors are just really
shitty assassins
that's what i that's what i'm renaming
it yeah
holy god man
yeah that was great so what is this the
speaking of ps5s the mall opens to sell
ps5s what happens
yeah i'm not running i'm not running
anywhere
oh somebody ate [ __ ] she's not getting
one another dude
dude he slid pretty far huh
look at how that guy slid dude whoa
hey no sound maybe would you run like
that
how come there's no sound i wonder
whatever you guys need to do i'll do a
run jump flip whatever
listen don't tell me how you get it you
know what i mean just get it
hey hey dan how come i don't hear uh
maybe it's just enough sound i want to
hear the
pandemonium people think it's not really
ian probably
say i am it could be maybe you got a
better skin update
yeah so
no way they're not getting they're not
getting happier
i mean yeah they probably have the first
like four people getting it
what then it's like okay um should we
all go get ice cream
no nothing's open probably
woman shocks her lady parts too explicit
it says
what do you did you guys watch this one
i think it's probably i mean it's
[ __ ] crazy can i watch it by myself
and react to it
tell me what happens describe it a woman
who she's
mostly clothed you don't see anything
and she lays on the bed
and spreads her legs and then takes a
taser and tases her cooch
what until she falls off the planet
what is that a sexual thing i don't know
it's really [ __ ] weird but i watched
it this morning i was like i'm not sure
if we
should show this she remains dressed
it's full of
cool it's clothes a genital torture
people are into that i guess yeah
huh i've seen some weird [ __ ] online
about genital torture bro yeah it's
probably
it's probably is that yeah
how do you follow that up how's it going
how you going to tear a [ __ ]
up harder than a [ __ ] someone here in
the chat
said i got a ps5 to sell i need the
money so how do i know this guy's not a
scalper
yeah what does that mean like you know
what i mean how do i know you're not a
scalper doesn't make sense
and then how do i know if you're going
to sell it who are you
right well how'd you buy it if you need
the money
then we'll meet up we'll go with the a b
we'll rough them up well who says he's
even here you know
yeah i don't trust i don't trust it
i don't sorry dude
i'm not getting i'm not getting suckered
not taking any risks with this
playstation
[Music]
he hit it so hard i missed it
you want to see it i'll show you again
[ __ ] it
the hat on a shovel
wow oh this sounds pretty wild
oh we said wait is this real guy
commented
what is happening he said i'm broke it's
digital
oh he has a digital how the [ __ ] wait
how will we redeem how do i know that
you haven't redeemed it i mean how does
this work
no i think i think he means it's one of
the things he's got the digits over yeah
i wanted digital but i don't trust
you
i can find a billion pictures why is
this guy being eaten by a tiger
lion what's happening
are they doing like the running of the
tiger or did this tiger just bomb into
this
village i'm not sure where the tiger
is giggling this video is so weird
yeah it's super rare other man
she gets weird and like she just gets
weird out there sometimes on earth
you know what i mean like dude that's so
scary tigers are
oh [ __ ] the tiger took a little bit of a
tumble too eh
and then it bails out it's so [ __ ]
fast it's insane
it's fast it's huge look at that thing
man you're dead bro if that thing wants
you dead
oh a pet tiger a pet tiger that got
loose or something
doesn't look like a pet to me i just
want a tiger like in my house i think
it'd be pretty sick
he keeps in the middle of the vibes over
here i want like a tiger a lion just
like roaming around
and like name it like xerxes or
something yeah
something tells me they wouldn't be
totally content in your house
this one's weird i saw it odd eyelid
pimple
[ __ ] that should i watch this this looks
horrible
all right let's do it eyelid pimple no i
don't want to do it i can't eyelid
should i do this i don't know no you
have to watch it
it's quick and easy i don't know
i don't like it i don't like it
not today not today
yeah not today guys how come you don't
want me man
sorry oh my goodness now now we're
talking
subway bdsm what
people are like damn too early in the
morning for this
why in the subway yeah it's one thing to
like have your own
like you know fetish behind closed doors
but don't don't make other people
watch your [ __ ] you know
what if that's your finish well then
then it's not an acceptable fetish
because you're including other people
without their consent
fair enough fair enough you know
oh explain this hilo what'd you say i
gotta
go to the bathroom watch this first you
explain this to me
and she's taking her finger her hand and
he's putting
it and he's picking his nose with her
finger
what that's what's happening
is she aware of course
there's no way she's not the only
explanation i can think is like
special ed and she's like his sister and
he just does this all the time
that would be the only explanation it's
the only explanation
weird but clearly this was going on for
a while because someone had time to get
their phone out and capture it
so there's a lot of other stuff to get
to you know tick tock
puppy girl who who was it this was uab
yeah all right i kind of want to wait
for you but let's get started
you want to i can read some donations
yeah read some donations for sure
okay let's see what we got here uh there
could be a manufacturing issue with the
amd chips and the ps5 that is affecting
supply
great show keep it up yeah actually
there's
i could be wrong about this but i think
the playstation and the xbox uses the
exact same
hardware or the same graphics
chip so maybe that [ __ ] [ __ ] up in
combination they knew
they knew that they would could have
been covered too you know
delaying manufacturing and everything
called viticus
see uh it's been a been a uh
troublesome year for that kind of stuff
uh
hey ethan big fan you call my friend a
[ __ ]
because he lies about watching the show
his name is jonathan
how do i know he's lying i mean i don't
want to call someone a [ __ ] donated 20
bucks
20 bucks all right your friend's a [ __ ]
uh
let's see what else pussycloth
exactly all right okay you look back
let's do this
so here ela this is on tick tock a
channel called official puppy girl jenna
uh she has a fetish where she
is a dog did you just pee on the floor
oh no jenna was this you
bad girl you know better than that you
pee outside
did you do this scooby dooby doo come
here right now
jenna come here bad girl come on
into your cage nope no you know you know
better than that
you stay in your cage you don't pee in
the floor you pee
outside okay you sit in your cage and
think about what you did
bad girl hey
i didn't know you're into a puppy puppy
fetish van
it is and she's got a lot of followers
twenty thousand i mean it's pretty nice
yeah
you want the ball you want the ball go
get it
oh they're doing this in public [ __ ] me
they're at a park with like in front of
a kids playground
someone saved me vin
really likes it though
what do you like about this van you guys
think it's a joke
you think what he said you guys think
it's a joke oh i
yeah i kind of do but i'm not going to
diminish your
this one has 120 000 views
who's a good spider hey why are you
twerking you want a treat
why what is that she was clearly just oh
she was wagging your tail i guess
yeah there you go happy halloween
[Music]
someone said i think we just have to put
the dog down
people get up to some weird and wild
stuff bro here they're back in public
oh they have a participant
the public is so weird for me
dude there's so many people there yeah
so just some random person who's like oh
[ __ ] around with
he's this making great money how
she has only fans of course he does okay
well who's going to subscribe zach i
already did
he already did tell me everything
do i have info here i mean i just have a
bunch of we can't you did it right
before the show
and we can't show it's it's entirely
nude so there's oh she's new dogging it
up yeah
so tell me about it zach tell me what's
behind the paywall how much was it
what'd you get
twenty dollars um
just the weirdest some of the weirdest
things
i think i've seen you know i'm not kink
shaming but
you know things i've never been exposed
to
um there was a dildo she put on a mirror
and then put peanut butter on the dildo
licked it off the dildo as she was like
barking like a dog
um there was a scene where she was
peeing
on some of her friends oh it's pretty
interesting so transcended into kind of
a pea fetish
too sure um what else
there was completely nude but written
all over body and
sharpie was like [ __ ] [ __ ] dog oh so
she's into like the being dominated
humiliated zach was there penetration or
anything like that
uh no they were not by a male
performer but by a uh a sex machine
oh a sex machine yes uh she's in cages a
lot
has a collar on barks a lot and were you
able to get off on this or was this also
just a proverbial warm-up
do you know this this was a little more
hardcore uh
i think i hope he didn't get off on this
because he was on the zoom call
once earlier
is there a jerk-off sesh maybe scheduled
for later today
uh you know i'm not really into the
animal thing okay
um yeah maybe down the line down the
line who knows
too far for zach wow you do you hear
that lady
re-evaluate your life you've gone too
far for that girl is her only fans
popular can you tell
uh yeah she it seems like she what do
you ever know
what notes ab she has she was making ten
thousand a month of uh
how can you tell that oh according to
vice yeah ten thousand a month i mean
that's great money
yeah that's really good money she's
about to make a lot more
as a side note and a lot of her tick
tocks you could see peanut butter
in like the background well for real
that's not like the
in the says jenna wants to get into bed
i don't know if that's a nod to her
she's washing her only fans
she has a duet on there of like like a
tick tock that you obviously can't post
on tick tock of
her duetting with a dog
and she's doing the same motions as a
dog
that seems that seems on brand yeah
while she's in the nude cool
excellent so 20 bucks huh nice yeah
shout out to jenna the puppy girl
vice did a whole write up on her that's
some really good pr how does she get
land that puppy girls the women with a
fetish for acting like cute dogs
puppy girls it's just her as far as i'm
aware
oh oh is that some someone else
either can i interest you in anything
like this no
all right just asking
psych you want to be puppy girl
no can i be a puppy boy
no no okay what's worse you being puppy
or me being puppy
uh you really
it's equally bad don't don't read too
far you don't want to deal with me
walking around on all fours on as a
puppy
no yeah what if i'm naked worse or
better
worse worse
[ __ ] crazy ass people out there in
the world man
there's a lot of stuff today you guys
can save some i've been going for hour
36 so far what about house of gourd
though
what about house of course so speaking
of house of gourd i mean
we can still do it but we all looked for
videos that
were this is not explicit this is the
only one i care about okay i mean we can
for sure watch this one we found like
two more
that are watchable yeah everything right
it's like way too much
so house of gourd we talked about them
before he's the guy who put the girl
in the carpet a hole in the carpet and
then covered her up and then went back
to doing whatever he does
so here's house of gourd back at it
again this is the worst thing i've ever
seen in my life
love me some house of gourd man why does
this [ __ ] look so old it's not old like
he's still up to it right
no we found out he's dead actually oh no
yeah
gourd's not with us anymore look at this
he's they're like in
like i can only imagine that you would
put like
a large halogen like what would you and
capture like this is a trans-atlantic
like cable wrapping
like she's so sealed i don't know how
the [ __ ] they even get her out of there
it's expanding foam they put in there oh
no yeah oh my god
this is so weird this is where it gets
really good
oh my [ __ ] god
so he died how did he die i don't know
if we found that
part out we just heard that he passed
away oh
brother what
she's pretty tall eh her leg's literally
gone oh my
doing god [ __ ]
wait who's there who am i hearing
there's someone else there watching
some psycho well there there's it's a
community a house of gord
i love it oh my god i'm in disbelief
oh gord passed in 2013 surrounded by as
many mistresses
and pupils oh he was he was surrounded
by
by loved ones and and disciples wait so
he's like
are you kidding me kennel what the [ __ ]
what is kennel cowg he died of
complication due to kennel sorry
kennel cough because what the [ __ ] is
kennel cough
dog skin yeah how the [ __ ] you get
kennel cough what is that
yeah it's for dogs what i mean dude
we're dealing with the house of gourd
here
[Laughter]
his most popular thing is called the
[ __ ] bender
wait where did you find that thing about
him dying from kennel cough this is a
dog disease
[Laughter]
to answer your question neil about um
about it being a cult i think it's just
such a niche that when you find
like-minded people
and someone who's so good at it by the
way this guy is definitely the gourd
the god the gourd of god yeah he had a
big estate
in uh i believe it was louisiana i found
out
which you see in all those videos like
that big property and it just
um you know people that are into this
kind of fetish they they all knew the
house gourd that was the place to go
that's the destination
here's another i had to beat off oh you
did trumpet off trump was a fan of
accord
i feel so powerful right
bondage auction so what's your name
i mean he really is impressive with his
knowledge of like
engineering yeah the materials very he's
a handy complicated
you could skip to like i think it was
like 20 seconds is where this uh
you're almost there oh another
farmyard farming thing once
[Music]
did you guys edit that how what was that
cut no that was
that's that's the video actually
because my hands was on some playlist
it was mostly the uh dragging around the
yard that
i wanted you to see
actually didn't see this far i'm cutting
away
bro holy either can i interest you in uh
some kind of farm uh work no
what's your profanity that's a good one
i've heard that wow
you know this one's good because it's
just called oh you guys re-uploaded it
it's just called 20 20 11 27 12 001 39.
i don't think that was the original
title house of gourd
the sprinkler [ __ ] device returns
starring so wait did he pay these girls
because he has his channel
he's got this community he says starring
this girl he must
be paying them no i mean well i don't
know
based on what uh ab sent us it said he
had
worshippers surrounded by his many
mistresses and peel pills
he's he's well respected in the bondage
world he's called
like isaac newton of bondage yeah yeah
they call his work ultra bondage and he
had like uh
favorite models and he he was like
people come out to visit him and use his
machines like he was known for his very
unique
machines you got to respect the guy
who's like so passionate about something
you know isaac newton invented calculus
this guy invented house of gourd
i feel like he's he is just as smart
he just has different interests
he looks like a character from you know
uh uh
king of the hill too damn it bobby
did you use my oh my god
did you use my
oh they love being machines
this is amazing joy does this turn you
on zach
at all
you're laughing but you didn't answer
not not necessarily sprinklers [ __ ]
but the bondage stuff you do like the
bondage but it's
really so impressive like you wasn't
interested
in becoming a sprinkler no i feel like
it's
a shame to me that like it's gotta be so
weird and sexual
but i like his um i feel like he could
be a good like sculpture artist
you know he's got a lot of engineering
his art that's
our idea don't try to change a man yeah
we have a whole write-up on uh oh here
you go ela there's a whole write-up on
house of gourd
jeff gord was a natural-born artist and
inventor his passion
was for inventing bondage gear that
would tease torment humiliate and
stimulate
very dangerous species women
gord's worked is often referred to as
ultra bondage
gord passed away september 3rd 2013 the
house of gore is dedicated showcasing
his life's work
along with new content featuring his
ulta ultra bondage gear
by his original production team and
starring many of his favorite models
house of gourd features photos and
videos of women who are being
trust stretched folded rotated clamps
suspended
not to mention penetrated stimulated
pumped inflated gagged electrified
house of gourd has it all [ __ ]
machines remote control
dildos automated vibrators punishing
tools mummification
metal cages two women bondage and
forniphilia which is human bondage
furniture
of course the website mentions that the
safety of their models is utmost
important
um house of gourd has a membership fee
that allows okay what am i going to add
go to casaboor.com
it's quite expensive 30-day membership
is 32 bucks
where else are you going to get one oh
you just get content
yeah just access huh remember
houseofgord.com
h3 i'm kidding that's not a real link
i just looked it up it is possible for
humans to get um kennel cough
it's just not it's not common well what
do you have to get up to to get that
[ __ ]
yeah if you have if you have something
like lung cancer or hiv you're more
likely to get it
huh yeah the guy lived
more interesting life he died in an
interesting
life in the interesting way all right
cool
[ __ ] house of gourd i love that guy
man
i mean he's kind of legendary but also
kind of it kind of scares me like what
else is he up to
that's not being recorded well he says
that like they respect each other's
safety and consent but like i j
i guess that's part of the kink right
but like when you're in a tube of
silicon
it's like you're he's just gonna kill
you maybe that's
i think that's part of the thrill is
that he could just leave you out in the
field
but he doesn't but he could
it's the implication
house of guard the house of gerd
i'm starting a cold guys called the
house of gerd
third gang sign me up
anything else before we wrap it up
i don't think so i think we've we've
covered it all
next week we have frenemies a fun very
special episode we're actually going off
set next week oh yeah
yeah i don't want to give it away but
we're doing some kind of special
adventure our first
remote adventure yeah for frenemies i
think it's
well the idea is really cool if it
gets hopefully there's no technical
issues of the execution but i think it
will be good i don't think so
yeah i don't think so uh we've got that
do we have a content court next week
gabriel do you need more time
no we we we don't we we have a uh
sort of traditional h3 podcast all right
we're gonna do
tuesday we're gonna do the the after
dark like usual and then we're gonna do
a traditional
h3 podcast top of the week kind of vibe
i have a lot of great stories to go over
i want to bring that format back and um
and then we're
finally i guess this won't premiere
until the following week but we are
recording
our interview uh with uh contra points
next week she hasn't confirmed
oh god damn let me check my everybody
keeps asking about it
we're trying to make it happen we
delayed it because we were supposed to
do it the week of the election and then
decided
because of all of the election
shenanigans it was unsettled and
everything that it would be best to
delay and so we've been postponing
we haven't forgotten about it it is
happening but it's okay there's just
been some scheduling
stuff back it looks like it is fine okay
so said
we're gonna record on thursday yeah so i
guess that won't actually premiere till
the following
week so yeah yeah and then after dark on
friday so yeah
um lots of beautiful content coming up
for you
any interesting calls or anything should
we wrap it up we should probably wrap it
up
i guess i'm so hungry we got we're we're
hunk over and i haven't eaten anything i
mean that's [ __ ] up
what should we eat you're supposed to
eat something sloppy and gross after
drinking took care of the hangover and
last night i didn't get pizza
i did not know why that happened so
chinese because
we ate mcdonald's and you still wanted a
pizza yeah wasn't that filling
that's not okay do it in the same it was
thanksgiving
what the [ __ ] at least acknowledge that
that's not okay
yeah on any other day i wouldn't even
suggest something that right
he's eating yes i admit that shut up
trisha don't fat shame me
well you're fat you're fat
you're a fat fat fatty trachea
you're fatter than i am you say it you
always say it
what the [ __ ]
um on any other day i wouldn't suggest
that you made progress because you
agreed that
most of the pizza that you get from
seamless suck it's awful okay it's it's
like we're getting
like some comments it's so annoyingly
bad i think we're getting to
agree more well that's the same we just
gotta we just gotta buy seamless what
like yeah like all that stainless is
like grub hub right you expect all these
like independently owned like
kind of one or two store pizza places
they have good pies but they all suck
yeah
most of those dudes it all sucks at
least here in l.a so i'm just gonna buy
dominoes there's a reason why domino's
has like a billion restaurants
domino hose is the best or or pizza
hut dominoes whatever there's a reason
they win the pizza wars because your
pizza
sucks and i'm tired of giving you all a
[ __ ] chance to make a good pie for me
i'm done and my wife doesn't even like
pizza anymore because i'm
trying to support you [ __ ] why are
you going to open a pizza store if you
can't even make a good pizza like
dude at least be passionate why are you
in the pizza business
why peach is actually very nutritious
well that's a [ __ ] lie oh my god
don't try to spin me that [ __ ] i
love pizza
and i love people hopefully not people
on pizzas though
oh i hadn't even thought about that
because there is a slight connection
there right
i've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30
days
i'm jealous tell me right now though
i'm starting the music okay tell me
right now what do you want
for lunch you want pizza dom and hoes
you do
are you just saying that because last
time you said that on the air then i
ordered things
no that's not true
[Music]
[Applause]
well you killed me in the game and then
i said the pizza is called
oh but that was a joke so okay well
let's not get into it
but wait you really you prefer domino
hose or pizza would you guys have an
opinion because i'm not experiencing
fantasy
quick tell me which one's better pizza
hut or dominant diamond house dominance
100
i mean i trust these two guys ian and ab
i think eat more
of that kind of food than the other guys
do
what's your favorite baby eats a lot i
see what you abs eating habits are
they're not good i've i've gained 12
pounds since i moved to california
really why it's the same food available
here that's in
detroit i don't yeah i don't know i
think because they're like getting
situated
it doesn't look like it and you don't
look like your candidates
it's all does lena complain
no no she's getting a little bit of
weight too but not a lot
uh-oh is she in there do you looked at
her
she's sleeping we're in a studio so yeah
you just wanted to see her fat ass she
looked
yeah i want to assess that she's
obviously not fat i'm kidding
i'm just joking about maybe baby so what
should i bring home for dinner
sweetheart tonight
okay okay we're wrapping it up okay i'm
getting pizza
well let's get one pizza at one dominoes
let's do a [ __ ]
let's just let's come on you let's do an
experiment we literally did that on the
show once and
you said domino's was the best that's
true oh we did yes
right we had this place the other night
called marcos that was pretty good
no i don't trust marcos i'm not i'm not
in any of these i'm not going off the
beaten path
at all [ __ ] marco you have baroni
[ __ ] baroni industry
say what you will about me but don't
suck [ __ ] on barony's
bronies
all right so we said dominoes okay
domino's it is
all right guys we love you thanks for
coming by it's always a pleasure to be
here on friday with all you guys
do that live baby [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it we'll do it live we love it
i hope you guys had fun i had a lot of
fun here today
we'll do it live [ __ ] it
do it live we'll see you guys next week
we got a whole fresh uh week for you
hot fresh content you will not want to
miss you wouldn't dare to miss
what was that just as empty
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it ah [ __ ] it
oh sorry all right guys see you next
time
bye see you next time bye dog
get you're listening to the hp podcast
what we got on the scene
could it be papa shoe nice or bill
delfin talking front weapon black wife
what you gonna do with me then you know
and the whole damn crew
goose and gaps with all the guests
you'll see the best podcasts in the
world take it from me jc
over chair hp baby we podcast
now you're watching h to the three
three three three you're watching h to
the three three
three you're watching h to the three
three three three
you're watching h to the three three